good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy Friday we made
it to another weekend in the queue hey
Claude hyd hey Jax how you doing
clanging here live in New York so
excited to be here it's Friday Friday
gotta get down on Friday honestly I
haven't been singing that much in the
queue on terms of zoom but something
about having this microphone like makes
me feel like I'm in a studio hundred
percent I think that you should continue
to sing I haven't heard anything
negative about your singing like any
time you do sing whether it was like
that dear toasters peak trine episode
like people really enjoy it I think
everyone's really been enjoying our
jingles our custom jingles for each
segment and I feel like we need to bring
more music into the show I think that's
a good note for us I'm so glad you
brought that up because I'm having this
moment on tick-tock where I found this
amazing
tick-tock er who he's like a pianist
he's like a bro he's obsessed with
Broadway he's an amazing piano player
and singer and he's been doing these
tick-tock videos of like famous
requested show tunes in different keys
and it's like I'm very musically
talented baverel anything about like
music keys or anything so I just know
that like some songs are too high for me
and some songs are too low so learning
what my keys are and all these different
songs has been so helpful and I do added
one of his songs his name is Dewey and
he deemed me and he was like loved your
video I used to love the morning breath
and I was like what no morning breath
juice that's crazy
and I put in a request so if you see the
wizard and I on Dewey's piano page like
it's me he's got the keys keys keys I
got the keys keys keys so you can check
out my tick-tock job that's awesome also
if you're wondering why cloudy and I
look like a little extra snatch today
it's because we just recorded a zoom get
ready with us for our patreon channel
where we like woke up rolled out of bed
and did what our makeup and what we do
to get ready for the toast together and
honestly it was like a little toast
pregame it's gonna be up by the time
this episode goes up and I think it was
just what we needed
today if you're a patreon subscriber I
would recommend watching the zoom first
and then this episode because it's just
like so in life okay so I'll post the
patreon I'll do like a
note saying if you should watch this
before you watch today's episode because
it's like chronological and if you're
not a patreon member you can become one
and get access to all of our old
episodes from the last like two years so
that's like almost 200 episodes it's
nine dollars a month for sorry eight
dollars a month 799 you keep making it
more and more expensive I can dream it's
99 for five extra episodes video audio
sister's been anything so check it out
patreon.com slash morning toast we
appreciate this court and we hope you
like the content yes we hope that you do
we have a great show for you today we
have some interesting stories today's a
very big day for music and we will get
into that but before we get into like
the light-hearted fun Kellie's mindless
news stuff there's something that we
wanted to discuss on the show because we
feel like it is important it is our job
to raise awareness and advocate for what
is going on in the world right now in
terms of the murder of George Floyd yeah
totally um I've just been consumed with
this story for the last few days it's
really been weighing heavy on my heart
as I'm sure it is with everyone in the
country so we just wanted to take a
minute to let our black toasters know
our toasters in Minneapolis just know
that we are here for you we don't stand
for racial inequality especially murder
like this is flat-out murder the police
officers involved not just the sociopath
with his knee on a man's neck but the
police officer standing around watching
they're all complicit they all should be
held to the highest standard of the law
probably higher because they're police
officers Danny just would be remiss if
we didn't mention it because it's been
weighing on us as I'm sure it I mean I'm
in the seasoned toasters group and I
feel like no one can even begin to
imagine what it's like to be a black
person in America right now but the
seasoned toasters it's just a window
into what it's like and people just
saying things like I've never even
thought about like someone saying she's
just hesitant to go out for a walk where
it's like I've never thought twice about
going out and getting some fresh air and
that's my own privilege and it's just
really like eye opening to read the
experiences of people who don't look
like you and if you're ignoring the
situation or you think that it doesn't
apply to you you are wrong and you are
complicit as well so we just felt like
we we don't do
serious stuff on the show but this is
beyond anything else it's not political
like this is a human rights issue and we
all need to be there for the black
community for our season toasters we see
you we love you and we are here for you
and if you feel like we do and you want
to do your part and help and get justice
for George Floyd and have those officers
arrested and charged with murder
a few places you can go to do that would
be justice for big Floyd comm or you can
text Floyd two five five one five six to
put pressure on the District Attorney
Mike Freeman to charge an arrest the
officers immediately because justice
must be served
yeah and I'm just thinking of his family
thinking of every person I mean I
listened last night Rachel Lindsay
launched a new podcast with ringer
called higher learning which I think
it's like it's less Bachelor more
intellect and [ __ ] great co-host I don't
know where he's from but he's so smart
and they don't really agree on much
which is so interesting and they
listened to the first 25 minutes which
is their segment on George Floyd and I
just feel like they sent me to Lindsay a
message because I just feel like she's
one of the most important women in
America right now like and you can't
help but think like if there were more
representation within bachelor nation
there would be 20 Rachel Lindsay's but
there's only one that's such a good
point and that's what I said turn like
I'm sure you deal with the most
negativity like I can't even imagine
what your dams look like I just want you
to know like what you're doing is
impacting me like I grew up in a bubble
and you make me see the world outside of
my own privilege and like I just I I'm
sure you don't get any messages like
this but I just wanted to know you're
making a difference and please don't let
people do negative things stop because
I'm sure she gets the worst that's such
that's that's so true I feel the exact
same way about what she's doing and it's
important for her to know that she's
making a difference yeah and to anyone
who might have anything negative to say
about us talking about this on the show
like while we don't cover serious things
and we don't cover politics this is a
not political issue to me like this is
just straight-up murder yeah I would
agree and it felt like I wouldn't feel
good about the job that we do here if we
don't use our platform to speak on
important issues
um mmm everyone in our community know
that we see them and we are here for
them and we want to help and we will not
stand for this yeah so we just wanted
our season toasts to know we are here we
support you we see we're here for you
and I'm really terribly sorry that this
is happening
yeah me too oh wow okay on a lighter
note what we do try and do here is cheer
people up get them you know just in a
lighter mood thinking about nothing just
laughing having a good old time and so
that's what we're gonna try and do today
even though it feels like the world even
the weather it's like cloudy there is a
cloud over this country today but we're
gonna do the best that we can to lift
you guys up today and if that involves
me singing I'll do it like I will do it
I think it might involve you singing it
might - I'm excited because we have a
fabulous segment of Kelly's mindless
news today and we're gonna recap Real
Housewives of New York which was an
amazing episode but there is so much to
unpack on social media afterwards and
I'm all caught up in the drama and I am
here to brief everyone I took like a big
poop this morning and I was watching
everyone's in serum stories and I did my
research and I'm here to speak okay wow
I'm really excited about that so without
further ado let's get into the fast five
stories that you need to know before you
wake up and take a bite out of your
morning toast
oh and Jack's you know what I don't have
anything to say today and it's actually
really sad do you want to know why I
don't have anything to say today I know
why but why you let him know why it's
had starting today was supposed to be
our summer Fridays because Jackie
thought Jackie and I thought we were
gonna be spending or summer gallivanting
around this country like partying and
sweating and tanning meat all these
plans for ourselves
obviously quarantine got in the way of
that and we have absolutely no plans for
the summer so we were planning on taking
every Friday off this summer to do a
little summer Friday and therefore we
have no ads on Fridays so instead of um
you know making money and instead of
going out and gallivanting around this
great nation we are doing this show with
no ads today yeah we had big big plans
for this summer and a lot of them
included you um not even camped
like other things that we were gonna do
and it was evolved us yeah it would have
been Volvo stopping in the office on
Fridays and instead we're here just like
not having me ads I forgot that's why we
took the summer Friday's we had a whole
thing planned for you guys to summer and
now we're here I'm so glad okay but the
first story is very exciting music news
Lady Gaga's releases her new album
chrome matica the 16 track album marks
the singers return to pop seven years
after her third studio album artpop hit
the music world okay this is their
exciting I feel like we've been talking
about this story for three months and to
me it gets no less exciting because the
album is here she just wants the world
to dance and I love this energy that she
is putting forth it's just so crazy to
think about because she was one of the
first people to delay her album release
and we reported it on it months ago but
like kind of before quarantine but like
in the middle of was like the very
beginning of quarantine yeah I mean
thought like when we got the Lady Gaga
album like we would be out and we got
the Lady Gaga album and we're in we're
in some people are out though so I'm
happy for those who are able to you know
go on a boat and listen to chromatic huh
um but for us I'll be listening to it in
but I am excited like I'm grateful for
the new music like even when rain on me
came out last week and I spoke too soon
on the show saying I didn't know how I
felt because I guess I didn't say much
other than I didn't know but like I now
know how I feel about that song and it I
[ __ ] love it it gets something going
in me and I don't care what the actual
lyrics are they are to me I'd rather be
drunk but at least I'm alive because
they told IR that is a mood Jaggi they
totally are I'd rather be drunk but at
least I'm alive because even if you want
to argue about it I'd rather be dry
whoever is singing it says I'd rather be
dry like there's a K in there yeah I
they'd rather be drunk and maybe it was
a 14 slip but that's how I heard it and
this song is amazing and so far every
single she's per fourth is amazing I
have not had time to live with this
album yet but I am so looking forward to
spending my weekend with it giving you a
full recap on Monday but I'm just
excited
um lg6 we've been waiting for this for a
long time especially since before this
we had
don't us a star is born soundtrack so
like that was the food and before that
was Joanne so we haven't had this like
an semuc Lady Gaga in quite some time
you know you know what the sign of a
great artist is or maybe I'm just such a
big fan but I really like love every
genre she releases like some people only
stand like the pop Lady Gaga but I loved
the stripped-down star is born
Joanne eras and I love the pop heiress
to like she really is so multi-talented
like she could [ __ ] remember and she
did Tony Bennett like she could do
anything she can do anything she's
everything of the sort and I'm just
really I'm more excited about this and
maybe I normally would have been but
it's just cuz like things are exciting
in quarantine that like when I have so
many sensations going on I'm so
distracted in my real life I might have
not noticed do you think not aware now
that we're like living in quarantine
it's not like a new sensation anymore we
reported a while ago that like Spotify
reported like less data in terms of
streaming but now they're like
quarantine is so much a part of us do
you think that people releasing albums
during quarantine are benefiting from
the quarantine or not like I think
people releasing TV shows are I think it
depends on the album okay like it
depends on the well it always depends
like if it's a bit out but they don't do
well but I think it depends on the mood
of the album yeah like it's Luis Capaldi
um came out with an album today like I
think it would be phenomenal oh my god
it would be phenomenal if Kacey
Musgraves came out with an album it
would be phenomenal um I have like a few
of like these sad singers who I've just
been really enjoying on the chorong
stings plays like the Sam hunt can't
album came out and I guess he's kind of
like a country like summer vibe singer
but like I think his album at least for
me benefited in quarantine because I've
listened to 2016 probably 1,000 times
because it's the first song on your corn
Steen's playlist so it always plays
first and that's the only reason like I
never would have selected it but it just
always starts the playlist so I'm just
like going with it and like Morgan
Wallen has been releasing some new songs
during quarantine I've just been soaking
them up I mean I think the perfect
example of a person whose music couldn't
have come out at a better time is Brett
Eldredge like his album should be called
corn
teen vibes like it's just so mellow but
there's a little like jazz in there so
if you're sipping a cocktail on your
couch like it really gets the shoulders
moving yeah it does
I'd love to talk like a radio host from
the 50s get some movement I know we
should do toaster radio of the 50s I'm
kidding
honestly like um that's really like a
patreon joke you know cuz I feel like
not everyone knows the joke but there
was just like a lot of stuff going on
with toast radio are you ready for our
next story
halsy reveals she's studying for the bar
exam while social distancing oh yeah how
was he revealed on Instagram that used
in studying constitutional law when
while in I salute isolation amid the
pandemic on Instagram the singer
revealed she might be working towards a
new career goal when she posted a series
of photos from her time spent in
isolation
amid the novel coronavirus pandemic
including a close-up of a book on Irwin
terminus keys constitutional law studies
when a follower asks why she was
studying constitutional law in the
comments section of the photo she
replied I'm studying for the bar exam I
just love her she's so cute she's
recently become like one of my favorite
human beings and this is so cute like I
love her like follow me in Kim
Kardashian's footsteps and this is great
like I don't know I just like I just
love her I just only have positively
she's so multi-talented and the next
time she performs an SNL she's gonna be
painting singing dancing and like
totally that was her essence was like
crazy and like she was I feel like she
for a while like was struggling to be
taken seriously as an artist like as a
songwriter and when she went honest and
how she was like just trying to prove
that and they totally like empathize but
it was a little bit of a weird
performance but I still liked it and I
just love her like good for her keep
going sis do what you got to do like I
love this for her I actually had such a
funny idea do you remember when like
legit two years ago I was saying I
wanted to go to business school yeah so
I never like pursued it I forget what
happened something just like it made me
realize that I just wouldn't be that's
it but
still have this GMAT book right here and
I never took a test
and I think I should like just take a
GMAT test and see where I stand like
this weekend that would just be like
hilarious yeah can you open up the book
and just like read me a question sure oh
my god yes I'm just curious like what do
they ask you in Business School like how
to show you hands like here's the book
oh it's outdated it's 2019 but this is
for people who haven't gone to business
school yet so it's like the questions
should be sort of just like are you
business savvy questions you know right
all right if you're putting a blender
okay I don't even understand the
question it was like a huge test prep
books give me like flashbacks to the
worst time in my life like waking up at
4:00 a.m. on a Sunday to take the SATs
like I actually have traumatic like
flashbacks wow so many of these things
are like based on you have to read a
passage and then answer questions oh my
god now there's like algebra maybe I'm
just not cut out for Business School no
part of like one of the major benefits
from graduating from college is that you
never have to go back to school like I
refuse like people who go to law school
medical school like I respect you but I
don't understand you like I hated school
so much I can't imagine choosing to go
to an optional school like there's all
these like this a green honey or a green
and I just maybe maybe I was right the
second time like business school is not
for me but I think maybe it would just
be funny to take a pretest and like see
where I'm at totally she was coughing by
the way thank you for not doing that
into the microphone okay you did Queen
oh nice I'm so proud of Halsey like go
get that degree um
fabulous I want fabulous that is nothing
but that's top things fabulous bigger
and better I need some things my
earrings help me get along and
a little fabulous is that so wrong
nice okay oh wait are we about to get a
chair look Oh sack chairman that's a
good one
he looks so happy last night and then I
before like he went missing and we were
looking for him and he I mean he just
loves her romp in the sack who doesn't
okay the story is really crazy and I
feel like you might have not heard he ex
I didn't hear it until this morning and
it's crazy duck dynasty's Phil Robertson
had an affair and just discovered he has
an adult daughter I know but this is
just like something from a movie the
duck dynasty family is bigger than they
thought
Phil Robertson and his children revealed
during the unashamed podcast on Thursday
that the family recently discovered the
deeply religious patriarch has an adult
daughter during the podcast all his
child explained that he received a
letter from a woman named Phyllis who
was 45 and claiming to be his sister
quote so basically it was from a woman
who said that by a DNA search she thinks
that dad might be her dad al said adding
that he had dismissed the letters at
first because the woman's birthday was
after the time Phil had become a
Christian in the 70s bill has previously
admitted to being a philanderer prior to
finding Jesus however it appears his
daughter was conceived just before he
devoted himself to the church still
married his wife Kay known as miss Kay
in 1966 the pair remained married um
mature drama in the Christian community
yeah nature drama I used to watch duck
dynasty like way before they got famous
I just thought they were so interesting
and weird and then they became this like
polarizing family and I honestly can't
believe that this happened and be that
they didn't try and cover it up honestly
respect yeah at this point like when
she's a 45 year old woman like it's and
she found them probably like through
23andme
it's just like interesting you know the
kind of like the scandal of it is like
taken away when it was 45 years ago and
you're more just like oh wow there's
this person on the planet who is you
know my sibling let's try
to them it depends on how you how you
feel about it but I feel like that's how
they feel about if they're talking about
our own podcast yeah this is just so
shocking I you're right I did not hear
about this but I'm so glad you brought
it up I don't think we talked about the
Robertson family enough on the show no I
mean I never watched Star dynasty so Who
am I to say but we did have I think it
was maybe Phil or the older one not Phil
Phil's dad when we had him on the
co-main red carpet what oh my god no
Jackie we [ __ ] a Phil we did no we
didn't I think we spoke to there's a is
that like the he's not the oldest one
but he's like the most famous when I
think he's like the thirstiest for fame
he is he's like a little heavier and he
has curly like shoulder-length hair okay
we spoke to Sadie's grandpa
sigh sigh okay yes because we were to
him
so much alike yeah I we were telling him
about Sadie's I keep Kim being the
trashcan Reynold Rainey decide Brett and
he didn't know about it but it makes
sense he's just the grandpa's like he's
not her dad oh my god Hana see my memory
so bad like the fact that I don't know
that we spoke to a member of the
Robertson family is bad like that's why
we can never get into a fight we need to
be sisters forever because you need to
remind me okay I'm here to do it like
I'm I'm here and I'm like no we did we
did we were talking last night and I'm
like told you a memory of maybe
something someone said or did or you I
forget but it was just like you hadn't
know like it was news to you something
like crazyland
my life is so exciting yes people like
tell me things that happen or that I
said or I did and it's brand-new news to
me like I'm genuinely like shocked like
I've never heard it before it's like I
get to live my life multiple times I
think that's fabulous oh I remember what
it was what it was something to do it
was like a business thing about advice
that someone gave you two years ago
someone who should be giving you good
advice if you like the worst advice and
you were like it was news to you that
someone
Jaqueline yeah that's funny yeah okay
next up um new couple alert and I need
to get your sauce on it because Nina
Dobrev and Sean white have made their
Instagram debut with a quarantine
haircut I saw this and they were like
they confirm their relationship and I
didn't even know there was questions
like I don't even know it's possibility
me neither
and it's like where's the rumor mill
when there's something interesting like
this you know the rumor mill is just
constantly churning like corn Lily there
: Lily together are they not together
but like Nina and Nina Dobrev and Sean
white were maybe dating this whole time
they're quarantined together and like no
one thought to tell us totally alright
hit me with the with the news the couple
made their debut on social media
together on Thursday with posts showing
the Vampire Diaries
actress giving the Olympic gold medalist
a haircut adding to resume hairdresser
she wrote in the caption on her photo is
white in the snap she holds up a pair of
scissors I mean the things I'll do for
word count just like describing a photo
I can't
I'm not gay um he posted his own photo
saying my hairstylist said he wouldn't
so she did um so it's basically they
just did a haircut it looks actually
pretty good the duo first sparked dating
rumors back in March when they were
spotted riding bikes together in Malibu
I guess like maybe we took that day off
and we missed it I guess okay I feel so
many different ways about this because
I'm gonna say something crazy I don't
know if this is like a popular opinion
or a not popular opinion but like I
think Nina Dobrev is so annoying
okay I don't really think about Nina
Dobrev because all of her things that
like made her famous are just things
that I don't watch Diaries but then I
see her like on Instagram all the time
and I feel like she's a really good
friend because she's always like on
people's bachelorette parties and like I
feel like she has a really good friend
of people in Hollywood and that's not
something that you see all the time so I
actually think that she's like a real
one but I could see how she comes off as
annoying on Instagram but like I think
that her friendships like speak volumes
that's a good point maybe I'm just so
like still hung up on that terrible
costume she did at the Casa Mego
party where she was a star is born like
searching for an Oscar like that was so
not funny and if you're gonna do
something like kind of outrageous at a
Hollywood costume party and have your
costume be about Hollywood like if
you're gonna take that risk it has to
nail it just has to be perfect
and it was far from that maybe I'm still
upset about that yeah now that you
mention it like yes I have a bad taste
in my mouth um but I'm gonna I'm gonna
choose to like push that down suppress
that and focus on the friendships and
the fact that like this is a really
interesting coupling for her one that I
I am tempted to build a little [ __ ] for
oh I have absolutely no temptation to do
that like I'll see where it goes I have
heard that Shaun White is like so scary
and mean so like I don't know you have
mmm he just like seems intense but like
I don't know why I like that she's just
like thinking outside the box in terms
of people to date well I'm also happy
that like maybe this will catapult her
out of like the only a Hollywood
storyline she's ever had which is that
the guy she was dating from Vampire
Diaries like ran away with someone else
and like she still gets into that drama
Nikki Reed yeah and each wire holder yes
so it's like they're so in love they've
been married forever and it's like he
was dating Nina right before he was
married to Nikki and she's like the Jen
Aniston like it's like it's her whole
life like all she does is get dragged
back into this love triangle which I'm
sure she doesn't like actually care
about anymore so I'm glad they were
talking about her about something else
like for that I'm happy for her I'm sure
this is like a huge weight off her
shoulders yeah I guess I don't know I'm
just here for it it just wasn't what I
was expecting this morning and I love
like being surprised in it in like a not
harmful way yeah exactly
okay did the final story a little not
like stuff news I don't even know what
to call it anymore it's like what it's
just like news about stuff miscellaneous
news miscellaneous news miscellaneous
news like that
miscellaneous news news okay you need to
start recording these miscellaneous new
I'm gonna do a voice note really quickly
so that we don't have it jingle a little
miscellaneous news I just have the worst
voice isn't like when I listen to that
my ears are going to bleed miscellaneous
news this beautiful Claudia that's
beautiful
okay CVS health tell tests self-driving
vehicle prescription delivery actually
think this is a great idea which is why
I chose it
cBS health will try delivering
prescriptions with self-driving vehicles
in a test that begins next month
the drugstore chain said Thursday that
it will partner with the Silicon Valley
robotics company neuro to deliver
medicines and other products to
customers near Houston area store a CVX
spokesperson said that prescriptions
will routinely be delivered within an
hour of being ordered customers will
have to confirm their identity in order
to unlock their delivery after the
vehicle arrives neuro has previously
started partnerships to test the
delivery of pizzas for Domino's or
groceries for Kroger also in the Houston
area this is the company's first venture
into health care to me this is just the
future I'm reading about the future and
I'm here for the future yeah I mean
delivery is everything of the sort but
going and picking up prescriptions is
notoriously like one of the worst thing
it's like going to the DMV it's never
ready there's always a line like it's
just an really unpleasant experience
even when it goes smoothly
there's always something they can't find
your insurance like there's just so much
on and then it's like in the bin 404
Ashley but you can't find it like
there's always some drama no one like
get I actually have to pick up a
prescription for Zach today and it's
just like a thorn in my side but also
like getting your prescription is
usually a day's long process because you
have to call it in then they won't have
it ready till tomorrow morning it turns
out they have it ready that night but
like if you knew that I guess in
quarantine it's different because like
if you knew you could go that night like
you would have planned to leave the
house um so you can go the next day but
then something comes up so then go in
the next day they keep calling you
leaving messages your prescriptions
ready you're like a [ __ ] no I'm just
trying to like find the time to come and
sometimes like doctors take a very sweet
amount of time to call it in when it's
like you're dying you just need your
antibiotics and they're just like
moseying down to the phone like it's on
their list of things to do it's not a
priority and I'm like ready to pick it
up and then we didn't get anything it's
just so dramatic yet and then we see
like two types of reverse curve
like sometimes I need to call in my
headache pills but like I have a few
days before I'm gonna need them but
sometimes like you're sick and you need
your medicine like ASAP there needs to
be like Evergreen prescription and the
ASAP prescription you know because
they're in the same it needs to be an
urgent line and a not urgent line
because I will never forget the last
time I had strep throat was probably the
worst case of strep throat probably in
the history of medicine I'm telling you
it was horrible
literally I couldn't even get to the
doctor for a few days because I couldn't
move I'd literally thought I was gonna
die and at one point I wanted to be dead
just so the pain would stop and I
finally get my ass to the doctor and I'm
in line at the pharmacy like holding a
few things like I bought a heating pad
and like a bunch of random [ __ ] and
there was such a long line and I'm
literally at the back of the line
sobbing screaming like literally in my
head my move I was miserable there needs
to be and there was just people there
like picking up refills like not every
prescription pick up is like the most
urgent thing there shouldn't be an
urgent line yeah I agree
well what I said this seems like the
future and I'm here for it and so I'm
also here for self-driving cars because
that means one day I could get in the
front seat of a car so very excited
about that those are the past five
stories that you needed to know this
morning and now I need to hear
Kelly's Mindless news I'm so glad you
asked Jackie in today's segment of
Kelly's mindless news like the fourth of
July
by the way okay when you sing it I don't
hear the correlation to shower but then
I had it it's Kelly Kelly's man listen
like the fourth of July whenever you're
around yeah yeah I got it
so you were wrong is what you're saying
no he's just like you were confusing me
but so you get it so I was right I'm
just double-checking you had a point but
you weren't properly making it listen
multiple times a day on the show I
always tell you you're right just like
give me this one okay you were right
you were right you got inside like a
today's segment Kelly's mindless news I
don't know how you could go and cheer
weekend without knowing that Kelly Ripa
recalled hilarious 7up fair miss app
before her high school prom according to
E news Kelly Ripa and Ryan Seacrest just
one throwback Thursday the live with
Kelly and my co-host are celebrating
prom this year with a very special treat
in recent months many students had had
their proms canceled due to the corona
virus pandemic and now Kelly and Ryan
want to make it up to them and let me
just say they're so grateful so the
co-hosts are throwing alive at lives at
home prom that is a terrible name it's
airing tomorrow well today on Friday's
episode Kelly and Ryan will be joined by
Jersey Shore star Pauly D who will
provide the music for the celebration
tik-tok star Addison Rey will also join
in on the fun and share a special dance
for the occasion and the pop band AJR
never heard of him will perform their
new single and in celebration of the
occasion Kelly and Ryan are also sharing
personal stories from their own high
school prom this is Kelly's high school
prom memory my memory of my prom ride
you will appreciate this I was setting
my hair and I really really really
wanted curly hair for the prom it was
the eighties after all so it was like
big New Jersey hair and I was setting my
hair but these spongy pink rollers for
extra curl and I was jeeping my comb in
water because I like to set it at night
so that when I woke up in the morning it
was super curly but it turns out Kelly
wasn't dipping her hair in the water
what I didn't realize was I was dipping
my coal into a cup of 7up I didn't
realize that it was a cup of 7up I
thought it was a cup of water and so
when I took my hair out of the pink
foamy sponge rollers and went to comb
through it the proof is in the pudding
listen I couldn't get a comb through it
for days
I'm like wow I just want to say if you
sleep with soda in your hair like
obviously it's not ideal but you take a
shower and like it's fine it's soda also
like it's it's good your hair doesn't
move isn't that what you wanted right no
you totally just like I just I want the
point of Kellis mindless news is to just
point out the sheer volume of idiotic
stories that are written about Kelly
Ripa everyday and I guess maybe a can't
blame her maybe it's due largely to the
fact that she does a show every day and
she like always is like sharing so when
you're a journalist like looking for
dumb things to write about celebrities
like it's easy to go to the person who's
talking for an hour a day but no there
are so many people who do daily shows
who share like tidbits about their life
every single day like that's literally
the point of like these morning shows
I'm not getting like Jenna Bush Hager x'
mindless news that's true I'm not
getting Hoda copy's mindless news yeah
it's true not even getting Ryan Seacrest
mindless news yeah he was like his prom
story was like shoved to the bottom of
the article I didn't even get to it I
wonder what it was like by the way if
you're gonna give us a promissory like
give us something juicy what happened at
the actual room um can we talk about her
name because it was I have a lot to say
yes please let's first of all I just
need to give a shout out to the setting
because for me oh that's what I was
gonna say meeting in my cage looking out
at the beautiful vistas of the Rhode
Island cliffs somewhere that I
absolutely must go to the Castle Hill in
if they would you know have us I would
love to be there those girls behind the
desk seems like toasters and if you are
like the way they were like trying to
smile and not smile when during the
never one walked in I just felt like
they obviously like are fans of the show
and therefore I feel like they're
toasters and I would love to be guests
at the Castle Hill Inn um it might me
I'll be there it just looked so
beautiful and like there's nowhere else
in the world that I would rather be more
it's right now than the Castle Hill Inn
yeah it was really like rubbing in my
face like a life that I'll never have
and that was really hard
I'm a stunning who even knew there was
such beautiful cosines like that on the
East Coast no it's it was really
beautiful
and I'll probably take a trip there even
I think I would have like been jealous
of it even if it was in quarantine but
obviously quarantine heightened to my
jealousy let's get into it because the
biggest story of the episode was Leah
and her sister and to me like I totally
respected that like if I was in a group
of new women and I was like can I bring
my sister like obviously that just makes
me feel more comfortable like for a
million reasons I would have wanted to
bring my sister and I I guess it is in
the housewives setting like a
non-traditional thing to do like it's
cast trips so I get why Ramona was
hesitant but at the end of the day like
it was obviously important enough to
Leah to like ask more than once like
just let it go yeah and Leah brings a
lot to this show already like just being
six episodes in and I think that like
it's like if Tinsley had asked to bring
her sister it would have been a hard no
but like when it's Leah it's just
different um and I I understood like
where the women were coming from because
like that is really uncharted territory
like this is a cast trip not a sister's
trip but like yeah I don't know it's
like to me as someone who like my sister
is just like an extension of my body
like I would be the same way like
whenever we go on friend trips I'm like
my sisters are just like invited if they
felt like coming you know so I'm no I am
my friends trips are my sisters right so
like I am the Leah in that situation
like if my friends were planning a trip
like it would be obvious that like maybe
my sisters might be coming but I also
understand like how the women rific wait
why but yeah but when it comes it's a
tiered you can continue it wasn't that
weird because honestly Elise feels like
a stranger so it's like there's one
stranger there already like what's to
write agree I haven't seen her apartment
like I don't know anything about this
woman why is she the last one to be
giving relationship advice I tell me
something about her I don't [ __ ] know
yeah when she was making Sonja and
Ramona laugh in the back of the car like
doing an impersonation of Dorinda like
she thought she was gonna be the most
famous Bravo person ever she was gonna
sell much I could see it in her eyes
like she thought that this was the
funniest piece of comedy ever written
and she's gonna be a star after this and
after tonight's episode I just hate her
so much for so many reasons the whole
episode to me was so hypocritical
because of all the franchises in all the
cities like the real houses in New York
have been embarrassment in social
settings for years and Liam like got way
too drunk at a private party like who
[ __ ] cares like honestly the way
Rinda acted at that billionaires house
in the Hamptons was so important the way
Dorinda acted at that dinner with
Bethenny in Miami last season like
nobody blinks an eye but it's like Lea
gets drunk and like puts her leg in the
air at a private party and all of a
sudden were just shocked and embarrassed
and glitching our pearls yeah I totally
agree when you're in a private setting
like you can do whatever you want
honestly her drunk antics were a
pleasure to watch like she was just like
a hilarious like having fun obviously
like expending energy and like getting
her emotions out um but nothing worse
than what any of the women have done
also it's so funny how like when she is
drunk like everyone has like a drunk
alter ego but she just goes into like
destruction mode like the flowers the
drapes like she just claws at everything
and I understand why she you know paused
on her drinking for a few years but like
the women are no one to even bat an eye
no it's so hypocritical and part of me
is so torn because last week I sat here
and I just really went in on Dorinda
because she's such a hypocrite and she
really goes for the jugular but she was
being the only one who was being like
not even she was just being logical and
like she was really taking lay aside and
she even Tinsley who was her friend like
wasn't really sticking up for her but
Tinsley's just not that type of girl
Dorinda was like really being defensive
of Leah and I was really appreciative of
it because these girls are so we have a
critical I throw it a little differently
um I thought Hensley was a good friend
because she was not embarrassed by Leah
whatsoever she was having fun with her
and she did not like add to the drama at
all
I felt like Dorinda was living for what
Leah was doing because it's typically
Dorinda who's that person and the more
she can like justify and make excuses
for Leah's behavior the more whatever
she does seems okay also that's a
tyrannous during this and the most
hypocritical thing I've ever heard when
she was like 10 Dorinda sorry leah is 20
years younger than I was like we
shouldn't be condemning her we should be
lifting her up and guiding her and not
being judgmental um take exactly what
you said and apply it to Tinsley totally
that's just like that's actually a great
point um but I was just I was just glad
someone was being outspoken through Leah
because like she was just get when
she woke up the next morning like the
judgment was Elise is out of control and
then bringing up her daughter like well
what would you do if your daughter your
daughter your daughter your daughter and
it didn't it wasn't before she said the
daughter thing like four times that Leah
finally got upset like what is the
unreasonable and disgusting thing to say
and I just dislike Olay Elise so much I
agree and also I will say for Dorinda I
was grateful that she was defending Leah
also because if Tinsley's the only one
defending Leah like Tinsley like can
barely defend herself and stand on her
own two feet like she's no one to be
advocating for anybody else but like
during the is a heavy hitter in this
group and like if Dorinda says you're
okay then Ramona and Sonja will respect
that also my desk is like so dust II
okay wipe it down because I like dust
flying like my nose has been itching
like I think it's getting into my mouth
right you're like it's just like this
dusty city I can um also I'm loving
Luann's positioning on these episodes
because she's really like staying above
everything but you can tell that she
likes Leah and has like a warm place in
her heart for her and is oh wait and
he's like gonna have her back if push
comes to shove yeah LuAnn has found a
way to not be in the nitty-gritty but
not be boring which is very hard to do
because well if you're not really
involved in the drama like I'm not
really interested but I actually look
forward to what LuAnn has to say and
she's so funny like in her own weird
countess way that that she it works for
her it doesn't work for everyone yeah I
agree I mean she's not really from the
table and was wanting to tell Leah that
her sister couldn't come and she saw
that leah was like so drunk and
emotional she was like so excited like
her and Sonya we're like let's go tell
her like to me that's evil yeah and also
like whether however you feel about the
assister coming or not coming like
whenever Ramona said she can come like
you just can't go back on that and even
if you regret what you said like what's
the big deal if you don't want to talk
to this girl then just don't talk to her
like there's plenty of other women there
it doesn't really matter if she comes or
not and like totally I don't get it the
social media drama afterwards was
between Ramona Avery and Lea Lea was
just going
in on Ramona last night just for being
so hypocritical like honestly if Leo
wasn't like drunk and running around
what would the episode have been about
yeah so Avery was Instagram storying her
and her mom on the couch watching and
Avery was like showing the videos of
Leah like on the grass and with her legs
in the air I was like mom I cannot
believe you're associated with this this
is so embarrassing oh my god mom you're
like the voice of reason like really
being super judgmental and making it
seem like Leah's behavior is somehow you
know what disadvantage she knew a
disadvantage to the life of a child
because we're at every 25 but she's like
a kid and kids are supposed to be
off-limits but it's like look you're
embarrassing Ramona's children what was
embarrassing about Leah's behavior like
she was just like jumping around laying
on the floor like it's not I don't think
she was doing anything particularly
inappropriate like it was a lot it was
it was crazy but I don't I mean and in
twenty-five-year-old like I'm sure that
you drink as well like things get crazy
and if you're just like clawing out the
flowers like and like doing somersaults
on the floor I don't get the big deal in
the grand scheme of like what you can do
when you're drunk
so Leah responded and she's like Avery's
25 she's not a child she's fair game so
Ramona if you really want to go at it
let's [ __ ] go it was crazy
oh that's crazy it seems like in IRL
Leah and Ramona is just not
yeah maybe gets worse throughout the
season because right now in real life
they are not friends yeah I feel that I
mean like Ramona's there her drinking
like I'm your mom and you're not no
you're not I agree it was it's just like
it's coming from her it's no sorry it
just needs agreed but it was a good
episode it was better than ones that
we've seen in the past and there's still
a new porn next week and there's more
drama Leah said on her Instagram that
Ramona shits her pants next week so I'm
looking forward to seeing that
wow that is exciting um it was a good
episode it was really chaotic
I loved the setting maybe like I've been
hard on the real houses
New York because they're in New York
City and I just like don't even will
trigger myself yeah and I'm just like
everything that's going on like that
goes on in the city like I'm just not
interested but what in the minute they
left the city I'm like ooh who are these
women
fabulous they were looking fabulous like
their fall Newport attire was everything
of the sort like honestly Dorinda in
that oversized cashmere v-neck sweater
with the matching scarf like that was
eleganza I agree I thought the same
thing about her in this look it was
perfectly situated for the situation and
I and I also love that like Leah brings
a young style to the show um yeah I
loved all of her outfits
I loved her hat I loved everything that
she was wearing I think she looked
really great and I and I did Dorinda was
actually my my style icon of the episode
never thought I'd hear you say that but
I completely concur that's funny that
you notice that you that that would get
cream sweater with the white I love like
a winter white on white I never have
done it in my life that I like when
other people do it me too it was great
speaking of TV the season finale of
RuPaul's Drag Race is on tonight and I
would definitely be discussing on Monday
so make sure to tune in I was just
reminded of that when I started to
scream eleganza extravaganza um justice
for gg-good I hope that she wins but I
have a feeling she won't and that's it
anything else trying to say before we
wrap up sis no that's all she wrote if
you want more content this weekend head
over to patreon.com slash the morning
toast we have five episodes up for the
month of May but if you're a new patron
you get access to a whole gamut of them
um today's get ready with us was really
fun and you know I think that is all
that she had written make sure to
pre-order my comedy special please it's
available on iTunes you can search
Disgrace queen you could search claudia
ashtray or you could tap the link in my
bio on instagram i would really support
it I appreciate the support thank you
guys so much for listening to with the
morning toast millennium morning show
where we go live Monday through Friday
10:30 a.m. Eastern Time on YouTube so if
you're watching this on youtube please
feel free to subscribe give this video a
thumbs up we're also available as a
podcast anywhere podcasts can bounce on
Spotify iTunes stitcher public video I
already have spots all the places so
ever you listen to podcast finest
morning telling five star view about a
beautiful stunning a smart we love you
guys so much have a great day bye